okay today I'm going to talk to you
about bonding
simply put bonding is the way that atoms
are held together in certain structures
and there's four different types of
bonding that we need to know about the
first one we're gonna look at is called
giant molecular so this type of bonding
is a type of covalent bonding
now what covalent means is we have a
sharing of electrons sharing electrons
now this type of bonding only occurs in
non metals because covalent bonding is
always only in nonmetals we need to know
a little bit about the properties of
some of these so one example of a giant
molecular substance there's two that we
really need to know about which are
diamond and graphite and we're gonna
have a look at those right now so
diamond has a structure that looks like
this what we have is loads and loads of
carbon atoms that are covalently bonded
together so covalent as strong covalent
bonds holding each of these together
this means that that diamond has an
extremely high melting point because it
takes a lot of energy to break these
strong covalent bonds it's a really high
melting point and boiling point also
with diamond it does not conduct
electricity because all of the electrons
are involved and shared in the covalent
bond so diamond
does not conduct electricity okay
it also it doesn't conduct electricity
it also it's insoluble which means it
does not dissolve in water
now we can see here the giant molecular
substances are this massive repeating
unit so this is just a small section of
what diamond would look like we have
millions and millions of atoms going in
every direction in a structure called a
lattice and structure so let's have a
quick look at graphite now graphite
similar kind of structure in the way
that we have loads and loads of carbon
atoms all join together with these
strong covalent bonds however the big
difference between graphite and diamond
is a graphite we have these different
layers because we have these different
layers graphite can actually conduct
electricity so there's actually
electrons but SUIM is these layers of
graphite that are free to move and carry
the charge so graphite conducts
electricity also because it's got these
different layers it could be used as a
pencil led because as it's pressed down
on the page layers come off onto the
page it can also be used as a lubricant
so lubricant and pencil lead now we use
it rather than the metal lead because
lead is actually poisonous now diamond
because diamond is so hard we can use it
as a cutting tool so that's giant
molecular let's move on and have a think
about simple molecular so whenever we
have molecular in these titles we know
that it's to do with covalent bonding
again sharing of electrons just like
this is covalent this is also covalent
which means also it's non metals now the
big difference between giant molecular
and simple molecular is that
giant molecular forms these repeating
units these big structures that keep on
repeating and repeating and repeating
simple molecular are much more
straightforward so we have these simple
small molecules such as Oh to co2 and
h2o or so known as water so what we can
see is they are they don't have these
big repeating units they have strong
covalent bonds in between the atoms but
apart from that let's have a look at two
water molecules even though within the
molecule we have strong covalent bonds
between the two molecules there's only
very weak attractions weak inter
molecular forces because they're really
weak intermolecular forces simple
molecular compounds have very low
melting and boiling points very low so
it doesn't take much energy to turn
these from a liquid to a gas or from a
solid to a liquid so yeah examples are
just these molecules such as Oh to co2
h2o or all examples of these simple
molecules not big repeating units also
they do not conduct electricity don't
conduct again this is because they don't
have any electrons that are free to move
so they did not conduct electricity okay
next up we are going to look at the
third type which is ionic now ionic
ionic bonding occurs between a metal and
a non metal so examples will include
things like calcium
fluoride or iron claw fluoride things
with a metal and a nonmetal a metal and
the nonmetal now the way that these work
is we have these big structures called
an ionic lattice where we have lots and
lots of ions remember'd ion is just a
Chuck and atom with a charge that's
either gained or lost electrons we have
all of these positive and negative ions
that are held in place so here is a
model of an ionic compound we have a
positive metal ions and are negative non
metal ions the reason why they're held
in place is because the strong electric
electrostatic attraction between the
positive ions and the negative ions
because remember in science opposites
attract so we can see whenever we have a
positive ion its neighbored by a
negative ion and vice-versa
as a result they have an extremely
extremely high melting and boiling point
because of this strong electrostatic
attraction between the two it takes
loads and loads of energy of heat energy
to break them apart
now another thing about a lot of ionic
compounds is they are in fact soluble
many of them are soluble which means
they dissolve in water the reason that
they are soluble is because the water
comes in and it breaks it breaks the
lattice of I breaks these ions apart so
the ions are now free to move okay when
an ionic compound is solid
it does not conduct electricity that is
because none of the ions are free to
move if we see when they're solid none
of free to move however if it's
dissolved in solution or if it's melted
and we've broken all of these ions apart
it does conduct electricity because
these ions are free to move and carry
the charge so when dissolved or molten
it does conduct electricity okay so we
just need to know about one more type of
bonding which is metallic bonding now
unfortunately I don't have a model of
metallic bonding so this only involves
metal atoms okay
so it just involves metal it does not
involve nonmetals remember these
sympathy's molecular ones and involve
nonmetals ionic convert involves metal
and the non metal metallic is just metal
now the way that this works if we have
loads and loads of these positive metal
ions and surrounding these metal ions we
have a sea of delocalized electrons so
all of the electrons from the outer
shell of these metal ions metal ions you
are free to move so they have a sea of
delocalized electrons okay because these
electrons are free to move it means that
metals do conduct electricity because if
we put a voltage through this metal
these electrons are free to move and
carry that
charge so they are free to move
therefore metals do conduct electricity
examples of metals include things like
just zinc aluminium copper these are all
examples of metals now the other thing
we need to know about metals is they
have an extremely high melting point
they have a really high melting point
because there's a large attraction
between these positive ions and these
negative electrons holding them in place
so it means we need a huge amount of
energy in order to turn these from a
solid into a liquid so they have a very
very high melting point
they are also insoluble in water so
those are the basics of our four
different types of bonding including
examples properties and models of most
their structures thank you